منين تمنيت واجب دور ال 16 اسبانيا ولا
المانيا
في من الفندق اليوم
ان شاء الله
الفوز طبعا المغرب
المغرب
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
نحاول نتفادا اسبانيا
اسبانيا شوي صعبه بس مقدمين اداء حلو اي
فريق ان شاء الله يا اهلا وسهلا شايفك
لابس علم الوان اسبانيا اذا لعبوا اسبانيا
والمغرب مين راح تشجع هذا موجود
[موسيقى]
ماني اسهل المغرب يا حبيبي المغرب الصبير
اليوم اساسي والاحتياطك احتياطي احتياطي
وانت رايك
ان شاء الله المنتخب
[موسيقى]
بقره صعبه يعني وايد خائفين بس نتمنى
الفوز هالحين صار الفوز مو بس مغربي صار
لك العربي نتمنى انه ان شاء الله تكون
مباراه حلوه
ولصالح المغرب
[موسيقى]
لا باذن الله التاهل مضمون للمغرب ان شاء
الله
وممثل العرب الوحيد ان شاء الله املنا فيه
كبير ان شاء الله ان شاء الله بعد ما
طلعنا احنا السعوديين نتمنى الخير للمغرب
وانه مئه اهلا باذن الله الحمد لله عندنا
لعب الكويسين مش عندنا اللعابات قويين ان
شاء الله بنفوز ليش لا بنفوز ان شاء الله
عندنا امل في الله سبحانه وتعالى يعني
الدوله العربيه الوحيده اللي طلعتها احنا
وان شاء الله ليش بنفوز بالكاس ان شاء
الله بنفوز صح ولا مش صح اه كلهم غال
مش موافقين ومش متوقعين لان التوقع
للفاسدين بس احنا يا خير ان شاء الله
ثلاثه تذكر هذا الفيديو ثلاثه واحد ثلاثه
واحد ان شاء الله